après les dépistages le ton des vaccins
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et depuis ce
lundi 18 janvier un centre de
vaccination une date très attendue à
l'âge qu'on à moi j'ai 86 gens et je
voudrais vivent encore quelques années
alors autant le faire par un autre
médecin qui a fait le nécessaire et bon
bah on a l'âge on vient pour vivre un
peu plus longtemps
- dr ils m'ont conseillé de le faire de
toute façon j'étais pour le vaccin
problème 845 d'eau sont destinés aux
personnes de plus de 75 ans pour la
première semaine
quand on rentre ici on est pris en
charge ces quasi militaire cetc c'est
avec une assistance médicale
d'organisation voilà tout tout tout est
prêt et se prépare pour pour ce moment à
saint germain en laye c'est un centre
social et culturel qui est transformée
dans ce site intercommunal 600 personnes
seront vaccinées par semaine près de
40000 habitants ont plus de 75 ans
quinze prochains jours vont être
constants à 6 ans et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir monter et accroître la cadence
il faudrait qu'on dépasse en tout cas
ici mille personnes par semaine on en a
bien évidemment largement la la capacité
après on va essayer de développer de
nouveaux centres sur sartrouville et sur
château et ça ça dépend aussi de
l'approvisionnement en vaccins et de
l'addition de protéines que les maires
et les intercours ont des moyens que
parfois l'état du mal à réunir et donc
il est tout à fait normal d'être aux
côtés de l'état pour assurer cette
fonction sanitaires huit autres centres
ont ouvert dans le département ce lundi
trois autres villes pourraient
accueillir des séances de vaccination
prochaine étape du calendrier fin
février début mars pour les personnes
âgées de 65 à 74 ans